these people are desperate to enter
Turkey they don't have many options at
this stage behind them lies the Syrian
city of tilapia
where Kurdish forces of fighting Islamic
state ahead the are chuckler crossing
into Turkey defended by Turkish border
guards they fire warning shots and use
water cannon if the people come to close
among the hundreds here are many
children Toki says it's taken in over
13,000 Syrian refugees in the past few
days but the crossing electrically has
been closed since Wednesday many that
did make it to Turkey have continued on
to Greece
around 2,000 refugees arrived this
morning in the Greek port of Piraeus
relieved that they survived the long
journey it's really dangerous the model
has broken three times at the road but
the ships the Greek ships we come from
Syria we fled to Turkey and now we have
come to Greece after this we want to go
to Germany and we want to stay there for
the people on the border between Syria
and Turkey safety in Europe is a distant
dream nearby the fighting over the iose
stronghold of tal Abyad continues but
the outcome is uncertain
just like the fate of the people stuck
here with nowhere to go